Les dernières semaines, j'ai eu l'occasion de vous rencontrer...
Bon... Pas tous, hein... Mais un certain nombre d'entres vous quand même.
Et ça a été l'occasion de constater qu'il y a une sujet qui vous intéresse
TOUT particulièrement...
Mes fesses...
Bon, OK... Pas vraiment mes fesses...
Non, en réalité ce qui vous intéresse,
la question qu'on m'a le PLUS posé que ce soit en convention, dans le métro, dans les toilettes des bars, dans ta ****** *bip*...
Cette grande question, c'est:
"Comment va Cyril Hanouna ?"
Alors... Pour ceux qu'on pas suivi:
Non. Je ne suis pas un pas un proche de Baba, hein,
mais je parle du tatouage que j'ai sur la fesse.
Alors, OK...
Dis comme ça, ça peut faire chelou mais vous irez voir la vidéo,
vous comprendrez.
Bref je vous avais promis de vous donner des nouvelles de temps en temps
alors je vous emmène avec moi à ma deuxième séance de laser
Générique
Alors petit résumé de l'épisode précédent pour ceux qui auraient pas suivi :
après ma première séance de laser pour retirer le tatouage y a 2 mois maintenant,
j'ai tiré 2 enseignements :
D'abord : ça fait mal, et ensuite : le tatouage n'a pas bougé.
Donc aujourd'hui j'y retourne pour la deuxième séance, avec deux objectifs:
1/ Comprendre si c'est normal
et 2/ Que le tatouage commence un petit peu à s'effacer.
Allez, c'est parti !
Alors petite précision, hier soir j'ai fait la fête, j'ai un abusé des bonnes choses, j'ai peu dormi !
Je me suis réveillé tard donc j'ai pas mangé, je suis à jeun,
D'un point de vue scientifique ça va être intéressant de voir mes réactions à la séance et à la douleur,
De façon plus globale, on va pas se mentir, c'est complètement con. Ne faites pas ça, très mauvaise idée.
Bon c'est trop tard pour reculer, j'y vais !
Allons-y !
*souffrance*
Là, ça fait mal mais ça va. C'est supportable.
Voilà c'est fait. Bon j'ai pas fait de malaise mais je fait pas trop le fiérot, donc je vais aller manger un morceau et je vous raconte tout ça après !
Voilà, j'ai mangé.
...j'ai même fais une petite sieste, j'vais pas vous mentir !
Bon, j'ai eu la réponse aux deux questions que je me posais:
D'abord, d'après le médecin c'est normal qu'après la première séance on ne voit pas vraiment la différence au niveau du tatouage mais,
d'après lui, le fait que il y ait eu des petites réactions blanches à la surface du tatouage pendant la première séance, et même la deuxième,
c'est signe que l'encre est bien détruite, et donc que ça fonctionne.
C'est juste que y'a l'encre d'en-dessous qui remonte aussi à la surface, du coup visuellement on voit pas trop la différence,
mais en vrai la quantité d'encre diminue.
Alors du coup il m'a proposé d'augmenter l'intensité du laser, j'ai dit ok, pour que ça marche mieux quoi !
*cet homme souffre*
La douleur avec, du coup.
Je lui ai demandé aussi à partir de quand les effets seront visibles, vraiment quand le tatouage va commencer à s'effacer,
ben il sait pas en fait, parce que ça dépend de la quantité d'encre et de la qualité de l'encre du tatouage,
et ça vu de l'extèrieur il peut pas savoir, donc euh... faut être patient quoi.
Petit bilan, visuel du coup:
ça c'est mon tatouage le matin, quelques heures avant la deuxième séance,
ça c'est mon tatouage quelques heures après la fin de la deuxième séance,
ça c'est mon tatouage le lendemain,
et ça c'est le tatouage deux jours après.
Bon, du coup on va dire que c'est pas encore ça, mais vraiment le médecin avait l'air tellement confiant que moi...
...disons que je suis rassuré. Et puis il reste encore quatre séances !
Et la prochaine c'est dans deux mois, juste avant l'été.
Ah oui, alors, le coup de faire en ayant très peu dormi, pas mangé et fait la fête la veille,
je vous confirme, j'ai testé pour vous: ne faites pas ça. Jamais.
...pas une bonne idée du tout.
*douleur*
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui,
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires si vous voulez que je continue à vous donner des nouvelles de Cyril de temps en temps,
en attendant, mettez vous bien, et portez vous bien !